hey what's up my name is samuel lees and
in this video i am going to share with
you why i am not doing this deal anymore
i was about to buy a property a project
development opportunity in
just outside of warsaw and i've talked
about this i've been talking about it
for the last couple of days at some of
my events however
something happened due diligence
happened and i decided to walk away from
the deal now i really really believe
that in property investment sometimes
knowing what not to do is as important
as knowing what to do because knowing
when to walk away is just as important
as being told to take action and to step
in so i had a property opportunity
someone actually at one of my courses
i've been running a crash course tour
someone um who i know trusted friend
that was at the crash course tour
pitched me on an idea of buying a pub
conversion just outside of warsaw and
i'm from warsaw so i'm like yeah man i
love the idea and um you know he showed
me the numbers he gave me a due
diligence
sheet and i paid
this person who is a friend and you know
a good property investor i paid them a 5
000 pound finders fee for this pub
conversion and the figures were as
follows he had negotiated to buy the pub
for 125
000 pounds i'm like cool
the pub already had planning permission
in place to turn to 12 apartments it was
going to cost apparently around about
400 000 pounds to turn it to 12
apartments i'm like okay great and that
means 400 grand in 125 you're talking
about 525 000 pounds all in am i going
to use my money of course not i'm going
to get um bridging finance or
development finance so i'm going to pull
in private investment onto the deal so
i'll put a little bit of my money in so
that was the deal 525 all in and then
the end value was 800 000 pounds once
all the apartments were done and
finished so you know there was about 275
000 pounds profit so the deal seemed
okay so what is the net percentage
profit on that deal and he'd done all
his due diligence so
uh if the end value was
800
800 000
which he said would be conservative
times point two five minus two hundred
thousand it's going to leave you six
hundred thousand so it's a good deal it
makes it stacked so i'm like you know
what it sounds really good so i paid a 5
000 pound finder's fee um
and that was that however
something happens and this is what i
started to walk out so firstly i
calculated the gross development value
i.e the end value of the property and i
think 800 000 was a little bit
optimistic so when i looked at it i did
some comparables now this pub by the way
he'd done the comparables by saying look
there's these apartments there's these
apartments that were selling for um
x amount which
so it was you know the due diligence was
done the problem was this pub was in a
slightly rough part of town sometimes
you can have a road
and one end of the road the house prices
or the apartment prices can be more than
the other end of the road so first
lesson is know your area know your patch
so when i looked at the the property of
the pub i'm like
i don't think the end value is going to
be 800 000 pounds i think it's going to
be more like 700 000 pounds so straight
away you've most of your profits gone
just on miscalculating the end value
however what gets worse
is when i sent the estimations to my
brother
ben machakanyanga he looked at the
property and he also said that he
thought that the um the cost of refurb
costs have gone up a lot the prices of
building which is going to block he
thought that that was a little bit low
only about eight or nine percent wrong
but the thing is if you're
10 wrong on your gtv and 10 wrong on
your co
on your refurb costs i mean that could
you could be 20 out well your profit
might be 20
so that means
you could potentially be making zero
money and then you're just refurbing a
pub for fun but you're not going to make
any money it doesn't make sense so this
deal looked great on paper but after
doing serious due diligence um it ended
up it wasn't actually a good deal at all
so i told my friend and he refunded me
the five thousand pound finders fee i
was within my 14 day due diligence
calling off period and now i'm not doing
the pub anymore i'm really disappointed
because i've talked about it i've been
sharing about oh i've just bought this
uh i've just played this funny i'm about
to buy this pub um but i'm not doing it
anymore so if anyone's heard the story
about this pub this is what's gone wrong
this is what's happened however
i actually think if i bought it and if i
did it up and if i you know i could even
vlog it or if i shared the success with
my students i actually think that you're
probably gonna learn more from what
didn't happen and what went wrong than
if it actually went successful and went
ahead there's so many lessons in this um
let me know in the comment box what do
you think the key lessons are from this
deal i think number one the first lesson
is um always make sure that you use your
formulas not your feelings when emotions
are high intelligence is low i wanted to
go ahead with this deal because i knew
the pub
i grew up in warsaw and i genuinely just
wanted to restore it but i needed to
remember that this isn't about what i
want to do this isn't about my feelings
my emotions this is about the formulas
of the deal that's the first lesson
second lesson is always be prepared to
walk away just because you've paid a
finest fee just because you paid a
survey just because you are invested
whether that be resources time money
doesn't mean that you have to go ahead
with a deal unless you're buying it from
auction or scotland where the rules are
different but be prepared to walk away
from a deal
third lesson is um prices of materials
have gone up a lot
in the last year or two so factor that
in on your refurb costs due diligence
due diligence due diligence get the
right team and professionals to go out
and look at your properties also know
the area well next lesson know the area
well make sure that you calculate the
gross development value i.e the end
value based on like for like comparables
not comparables quarter of a mile away
that are actually in a better side of
town so i thought i'd share this video
with you for complete transparency so
you can see what i'm doing and i hope
you learned some valuable lessons if you
want to see more videos like this you
can subscribe right up here also there's
a whole playlist of videos of properties
that have gone wrong and things that
haven't worked out so if you want to
learn from my mistakes check out the
playlist right here and i hope you can
join me at the property millionaire
intensive where i'm going to be sharing
how to make money from property not just
buying properties and renting them out
but actually pushing the value up and
then selling them or refinancing them
hope to see you there thanks for
watching